[Musique]
qui étaient 16 ans comme chancelier
mouvementé et souvent très
années difficiles qu'ils m'ont
politiquement et humainement nécessaire et
en même temps ils m'ont toujours aussi
remplit particulièrement le passé
nous avons deux ans de pandémie dans
montré par une loupe de quelle grande
c'est-à-dire la confiance dans la politique
la science et le social
le discours, c'est aussi sa fragilité
peut être
notre démocratie se nourrit de la capacité
pour une discussion critique
et pour l'autocorrection
elle vit de l'installation tardive des
Intérêts
et le respect de l'autre
il se nourrit de solidarité et de confiance
de plus, aussi de la confiance dans
faits et que partout là où
connaissances scientifiques niées
théories du complot et discours de haine
être répandu
contradiction doit être soulevée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]